We now would like to
consider the motion
of a rigid body that's
undergoing angular
acceleration about some axis.
So let's consider, for
simplicity, a disk.
And we have an axis that's
passing through some point,
as here is the center,
but that's not crucial.
And we want to consider
the fact that this object--
we'll call this our
Z-axis-- K hat unit
vector in that direction.
So it's pointing up.
And this object is undergoing
an angular acceleration
where alpha Z is the Z component
of the angular acceleration.
Now, what we'd like to consider
is the torque on the subject.
So the way we'll do it is
we'll divide the object
into a bunch of pieces.
And let's identify a
piece here as Delta MJ.
That's that piece.
And this piece has some
force acting on it.
Now, this force can be a vector.
But the important
thing to realize
is that this force is
only the external force,
because we've
already got to make
the assumption that all internal
torques cancel in pairs.
And we'll show that in the
video a little bit later.
So we're only considering
the external forces that
are acting on this element.
And recall that we
have the vector.
RS to J is the vector.
From point S to where
this mass element is.
And now what we'd like to
do is calculate the torque.
In general torque is
given by the expression--
we'll sum over all the elements.
J goes from 1 to N. And it's the
cross-product of our SJ cross
FJ external.
Now, our goal here
is only to calculate
the Z component of the torque.
So we can simplify
our understanding
a little bit by writing out
this vector F external J
as a component in the plane.
And in order to describe that
we'll choose some unit vectors.
R hat theta hat
going into the plane.
We'll make another
picture in a moment.
So our vector can
have an R component.
And I'll keep the
external in there.
It can have a theta
hat component.
And it can also
have a Z component.
But recall that a
cross-product is always
perpendicular to
either of the elements.
So when I cross R with
anything in the K direction
then that component
will give a component
that's not in the Z direction,
and so I can ignore that.
So my first simplification is
to say that the Z component will
only come from the cross product
of RSJ, with these two pieces.
So that's cross FJR R hat
plus FJ theta theta hat.
Now, again we can make
another simplification,
and perhaps here it's helpful
to have another overhead view.
And here's our mas
element, delta NJ.
That's our vector from F,
from the center, to delta NJ.
We have unit vectors,
R hat, and theta hat.
And so we see that this vector,
RSJ, has some length in the R
hat direction.
So we're picking S as the
origin of our coordinate system.
This can generalize.
So we don't worry about if
the object is not symmetric.
So when you take the cross
product of R hat verse R hat,
that also is zero.
And so we see our simplification
is quite nice, that the Z
component of the torque, is
only arising from the sum of J
goes from 1 to N of our RSJ.
Well, we've already-- we'll
write this all as vectors.
R ht cross F J theta theta hat.
Now, again, even if our
external force-- by the way,
we're dropping external.
We can always say external, but
I think, for simplicity, we'll
now drop the external.
And what we're
considering is just
the component of the force.
We can write that FJ-- this is
a little complicated-- theta.
Just the theta hat
component of that force.
This is the only
piece of the force
that matters in contributing to
the Z component of the torque.
And this cross-product
is very direct
because we've chosen a
right handed system, where
R hat cross theta hat is K hat.
So we see that this
becomes J equals 1
to N of RSJ FJ theta
in the K hat direction.
Now, that's just the
calculation of the torque.
But, as always, it's
crucial to understand
where Newton's second law
appears in these calculations.
And Newton's second law,
for this mass element,
delta MJ, So the second
law is telling us
that the tangential
force is proportional
to the mass element times
the tangential acceleration
of that mass element.
Now, for this type of
rotation about the Z-axis.
So when we're rotating
about that Z-axis
we know that AJ theta,
so the acceleration
of this tangential element,
is just proportional
to RJ distance from-- well
we've called that our RSJ--
so how far away from the center?
And here's the key thing.
It's also proportional to the
Z component of the angular
acceleration.
And every mass element in the
body has the same alpha Z.
And so our sum, for
the torque, can now
be written in the following way.
The Z component of
the torque-- now,
I'm going to do
something here, which
is, I'll write J equals 1
to N, a parnetheses mark.
I have one of the RSJs.
I have another RSJ.
A delta MJ.
So I have delta MJ RSJ squared.
But every single component
has the same alpha Z.
And we're in the
K hat direction.
Now, because we have a
continuous body we have to,
again, consider a limit.
So let's call the limit as
delta MJ goes to 0 of this sum,
delta MJ RSJ squared.
Well that's an integral over
the body of DMRS squared.
And we identified that before
as the moment of inertia
about the Z-axis.
So the quandary in
parentheses is just
a measure of the mass
distribution about the axis.
You see the R
squared, the delta MJ.
And so in conclusion we
have that the Z component
of the torque is
equal to IS alpha Z K
hat, which is now a vector,
because that's the vector
alpha.
And this is our crucial
result for a body that's
rotating about the Z-axis.
This result can
generalize to not just
a disk, but any body that's
looking at the Z component,
for this fixed axis rotation.